Democrats pass a resolution condemning
president Trump's quote-unquote racist
tweets the squad prepares to go back to
war with Nancy Pelosi and Republicans
struggle to react I'm Ben Shapiro this
is the Ben Shapiro show well it's all a
complete mess out there unclear how all
of this shakes out in terms of the
polling data
AOC at war with Nancy Pelosi Nancy
Pelosi at war with the squad and
president Trump president Trump at war
with anyone the media at war with
everyone as well it's just it's a
complete mess we'll get to all of it in
just one second first let me tell you
about hiding it a great suit I know
you're going down to the local
department store and you figure you'll
just pick something off the rack and
it'll look right wrong that you are what
you actually need is a suit and shirt
that are tailored to you well this is
where endo Chino comes in they make the
suits and the shirts to your exact
measurements for an unparalleled fit and
comfort my favorite suit is an Indo
Chino suit
they've got attention to detail that
you're just not gonna find at department
stores if you're in the middle of
planning a wedding they have tons of
options for people looking to outfit
their wedding party they've got a wide
selection of high quality fabrics and
colors to choose from plus they have the
option to personalize the details
including your lapel lining pockets
buttons writing your own monogram so
here's how it works
you can visit a stylist at one of their
showrooms or you can measure at home and
then shop online at Indo Chino com you
can choose your fabric and design
customizations simply submit your
measurements with your choices online
relax while your suit gets
professionally tailored and mailed to
you in a couple of weeks this week my
listeners can get any premium Indo Chino
suit for just 369 bucks at Indo Chino
comm when you enter Shapiro at checkout
that's 50% off the regular price for a
made to measure premium suit again
shipping is free that's Indo Chino kaam
promo code Shapiro for any premium suit
just 359 Bucks free shipping incredible
deal for a premium made-to-measure suit
look like James Bond
once he go custom you're not gonna want
to go back alrighty so yesterday late in
the day the House of Representatives
passed a resolution condemning president
Trump's quote-unquote racist tweets for
Republicans voted along with all the
Democrats to condemn president Trump's
quote unquote racist tweets according to
NBC News the Democrat controlled House
of Representatives passed a resolution
Tuesday night condemning President Trump
for his quote racist comments about for
Democratic Congress women of color the
resolution passed largely along party
lines with 235 M
that's joined by only four Republicans
supporting the measure following hours
of back sent back and forth and
gamesmanship there is a lot of hubbub
that broke out last night because Nancy
Pelosi used language that was not
actually allowed by the house rule so
there are house rules that prevent you
from impugning the motives of the
President of the United States or other
members of the of the members of the
house or of the Senate well Nancy Pelosi
did that on the floor of the house the
resolution itself says that the
president used quote/unquote racist
language so that is impugning the
motives of the President of the United
States it violates the house rules now
listen I think those house rules are
stupid let's be real about this Congress
members immediately leave the chamber
and then say whatever they want to say
about each other anyway saying they
can't say this stuff on the floor of the
house has not really upped the game of
the House of Representatives in Britain
they rip each other all the time I mean
they have full-on parliamentary sessions
where they basically browbeat one
another I'm fine with that I think this
is a dumb rule but it was the rule Nancy
Pelosi broke it here's Nancy Pelosi
yesterday on the floor of the house
talking about how she's speaking truth
to power now obviously this is a life
he's not speaking truth to power at all
one of the ways that you know whether
somebody is honest is whether they are
willing to condemn people on their own
side for doing something bad
Nancy Pelosi not only will not speak
truth to power to the President of the
United States she's the third most
powerful person in American government
really the second most powerful cuz the
VP has no real power she's third in line
for the presidency she runs the House of
Representatives and she's saying that
she's speaking truth to power by not
impeaching President Trump she's got a
lot of power second of all she couldn't
even get the support to condemn members
in her own party for being clearly and
openly anti-semitic so don't give me she
speaks truth to power she doesn't she
wields racism as a political tool in
favor of her partisan agenda which as we
will see is one of the reasons they're
getting a anti anti Trump backlash right
so there's this anti Trump backlash
people pushing against Trump and then
you have people who are anti anti Trump
saying well all the people who are
condemning Trump they're compromised in
some way morally they're liars the
partisan hacks like Nancy Pelosi so I'm
not gonna go along with the condemnation
of Trump just to make Nancy Pelosi happy
I think that's one of the dynamics that
is very strongly in play right now
here's Nancy Pelosi though patting
herself on the back talking about how
she's speaking truth to power when she
won't even condemn members of her own
caucus for being openly bigoted every
single member of this
and Democratic and Republican to join us
in condemning the president's racist
tweets to do anything less would be a
shocking rejection of our values and a
shameful abdication of our oath of
office to protect the American people I
urge a vote and yield back the balance
of my I was just gonna give the general
speaker of the house that she would like
to rephrase that comment I had cleared
my remarks as a parliamentarian before I
read them okay and that little
controversy right there that little
contretemps back and forth that was
representative that those representative
from Georgia who stood up and said
listen you just violated the rules of
the house were not allowed to impugn the
motives of the President of the United
States would you like to strike that she
said I cleared it with the
parliamentarian apparently she had not
because the parliamentarian then ruled
that her language did violate the rules
of the house and so there are rules that
say that that she now has to not speak
for the rest of the day and her language
has to be struck from the record Emanuel
cleaver was the chair of the house at
the time he was chairing the house you
can sort of pass the gavel back and
forth to particular members of your
caucus he was chairing this thing the
parliamentarian ruled that Pelosi's
words were out of order that they broke
the rules Emanuel cleaver refused to say
that they broke the rules so instead he
just said I'm gonna drop the gavel and
leave I came in here to try to do this
in a fair way I kept warning both sides
let's not do this hoping we could get
through mr. Paul had a situation where
we could be in here on another motion to
[Music]
take down words of of a friend of mine
and but we don't ever ever want to pass
up it seems an opportunity to escape and
that's what this is out there anybody to
look at any of the footage and see if
there was any unfairness what unfairness
is not enough because we want to just
fight abandon the chair okay so he walks
off violates the rules of the house
right in order to protect Nancy Pelosi
for violating the rules of the house and
Stinney Hoyer who's the House Majority
Leader he gets up he takes the gavel and
he says yeah it turns out she broke the
rules and now she can't talk
the rest of the day chair is prepared to
rule the words of the gentlewoman from
California contain an accusation of
racist behavior on the part of the
President as memorialized in Nationals
precedence chapter 29 section 6 B 5
point 6 characterization characterizing
an action as racist is not in order the
chair relies on the precedent of May
15th 1984 and finds that the words
should not be used in debate okay and
then the House votes to basically change
the rules for Nancy Pelosi rules the
words back in order
votes on the resolution rules the Pelosi
has done nothing wrong so there's this
whole back-and-forth over violating the
rules now again I think the rule itself
is stupid because these Congress people
will just go out and say whatever they
want anyway however that sort of hubbub
last night proved again that there's
nothing but chaos in the House of
Representatives okay so the question
becomes the Nancy Pelosi says everybody
of good heart should vote with us on
this resolution every one of good heart
should vote with us on this resolution
there are several reasons why
Republicans were not going to vote on
this resolution the way that it was
phrased the reason number one is that it
is actually controversial whether the
president was being racist or xenophobic
now this is a distinction that actually
does matter in American politics why
well because the word racist is the
worst thing you can be called in
American politics if you're a racist in
American politics then your political
career is basically over and we tend to
categorize anybody who supports that
person has also a racist right there's a
move that we make in modern American
politics where if a politician is
perceived as being a racist because race
is the great dividing line in the
history of the United States and the
great stain on our national honor for
the first 150 200 years of our existence
and my existence I've been dating back
to 1776 not to the Mayflower Compact or
anything like that
if you're talking about slavery it goes
back hundreds of years further than that
obviously but the the use of the word
racist to label somebody or somebodies
action basically throws them outside the
Overton Window of politics and so to
label the President of the United States
racist means that he should not be
president anymore under today's modern
American political definition so the
distinction between racists and
xenophobes
does matter here there's also an aspect
of stupid meaning that president from
says crap a lot and it's usually very
stupid and many of the stupid things
that President Trump tends to say are
directed in the drunk uncle at your
family barbecue direction meaning is he
a true deep down bigoted racist who
believes that black folks are inferior
and brown people can't be good American
citizens or is the president just
somebody who's like a bad caller to a
c-span show and he sees Rasheeda Talib
and Ilhan Omar on TV and say I don't
like these people they just go back
where they came from because I don't
like these people and when you say the
same thing about somebody who is white
and part of that caucus I don't know you
don't know nobody knows because the
Justice Democrats are represented by for
women of color
right-eo C and Rasheeda Talib and Yohan
Omar and and Ayanna Presley the Ringo
Starr of this this Beatles group so you
know when Trump condemns them and when
he says they should all go back where
they came from
is that a representative of racism or is
that him assuming that everybody who
disagrees with him comes from a foreign
place and if they're a white member of
that caucus would he spare that person
for example these questions matter again
because the word racist is so charged in
modern American life and the reason that
you can tell that this is really charged
is people are saying on the left well
why won't Republicans just universally
come out and say that this was racist
again because you have to be sort of
exact in your language when you're
labeling something racist as opposed to
merely xenophobic now the reason that I
make this this sort of context clear is
because I want to take the text of the
resolution that was voted on yesterday
and contrast it with the text of the
resolution that was voted on earlier
this year that received unanimous
support condemning representative Steve
King from Iowa so here is the text of
the resolution condemning Steve King of
Iowa who made comments that were sort of
complimentary toward white nationalism
here's the resolution okay said
condemning and censuring representative
Steve King of Iowa the House Republicans
voted for this thing and it was
sponsored by House Republicans so
Democrats couldn't condemn their own but
Republicans certainly did when it came
to Steve King nowhere in the resolution
did it call King racist instead it was
very specific it said whereas On January
10th 2019 in an interview published by
the New York Times representative Steve
King asked white nationalists white
supremacists Western civilization how
did that language become offensive why
did I sit in class
teaching me about the merits of our
history and our civilization whereas
representative King's comments
legitimized white supremacy and white
nationalism as acceptable in today's
society whereas representative King's
comments are important to the founding
principles of our nation and our rich
history of diversity and tolerance of
those whose backgrounds and beliefs have
made America the envy of the world
and whereas representative King's
comments reflect negatively on the House
of Representatives now therefore be it
resolved that representative King be
censured and that passed unanimously
well again the reason that it passed
unanimously is because it didn't
characterize his comments it literally
repeated his comments and then just made
the very clear logical statement that
they legitimized white supremacy and
white nationalism the resolution that
was adopted by the Democrats went
further than that the resolution adopted
by the Democrats ladled in a lot of
their own immigration policy and also
suggested without real explanation not
even quoting his tweets they just said
we're as president Trump's racist
comments have legitimized fear and
hatred of new Americans and people of
color that's that's more of a
characterization of his statements than
a mere Namira analysis of what the man
said whether the the actual resolution
does not even quote his tweets in the
first place as opposed to the resolution
that was about Steve King that quoted
his tweets and then just said here's
what he said so this was obviously going
a lot further than the Steve King
resolutions that was reason number one
that Republicans didn't vote for but
there are other reasons that Republicans
didn't vote for and and those reasons
are revealed by a couple of polls that
are out today regarding how Americans
view president Trump's comments and the
response to Trump's comments and it
really is fascinating because there's a
conversation going on in which the two
sides I think are completely missing one
another I'll get to that in just one
second first when the founders crafted
the Constitution the first thing they
did was to make sacred the rights of the
individual to share their ideas without
limitation by their government that
would be the First Amendment the second
right they enumerated was the right of
the population to protect that speech
and their own persons with force that
would be the Second Amendment of course
I am a second Amendment lover and
defender because we need to be able to
defend our rights we needed to be able
to defend our liberty and our safety
from people who come to hurt us owning a
rifle is an awesome responsibility and
building rifles is no different started
in a garage by marine vet more than two
decades ago bravo company manufacturing
BCM for short those are professional
grade products which is built to combat
standards Bravo
company manufacturing is not a sporting
arms company they're interested in
designing engineering and manufacturing
life-saving equipment the people at BCM
assume that when a rifle leaves their
shop it will be used in a life-or-death
situation by a responsible citizen law
enforcement officer or a soldier
overseas to learn more about bravo
company manufacturing head on over to
bravo company MFG comm the folks who
running are just fantastic you can
discover more about their product
special offers upcoming news their
products are terrific
check them out bravo company MFG comm if
you need more convincing check them out
at youtube.com slash bravo company USA
awesome rifles built by great folks
youtube.com slash bravo company USA ok
so when you look at the polling data
surrounding people's perceptions of
President Trump's comments what you see
is that there are two questions that are
being perceived question one is what is
the content of what Trump said do you
like it or do you not and that's the
question left thinks they're asking but
that's not really the question the right
things that the left is asking them so
Nancy Pelosi will get up there and say
why can't you just condemn these
comments and folks on the right are
looking at her going because you're the
one asking and because you are willing
to overlook racism and bigotry and
anti-semitism in your own party and so
we think you're a political hack who is
not actually making a clear-eyed
assessment of what the president is
saying we think instead that what you
are doing is weaponizing the president's
comments and and attacks on on race or
ethnicity more generally in favor of
your own political side right that is
the that is is what people are reading
and you can see this in the polling data
you see this very often with with a lot
of hot-button political issues somebody
will pick a hot-button political issue
and then they will say why can't you
admit my point and the answer is because
we don't think that your point derives
from the material that you are relying
upon so to take an example the black
lives matter movement was founded on the
belief that black people are being
disproportionately targeted by police
and then they used as their basis for
that the Ferguson shooting the Ferguson
shooting was not by all available data a
bad shoot by the police officer it was
not a racist shooting by the police
officer and yet the question that was
being asked routinely is so you don't
think racism exists in America now
everyone believes racism exists in
America but you're asking the wrong
question so you are pointing at Ferguson
or you're pointing at disproportionate
police shootings of black folks which in
statistically speaking have generally
been shown to be justified by Roland
fryer over at Harvard University based
on the activities of the criminal
latisha and then you are saying are you
saying racism doesn't exist in America
it's like no I'm saying racism does
exist in America but the evidence you're
providing for this is not clear and it
feels like you are asking me to say yes
so that you can then justify the rest of
your agenda this sort of thing happens
routinely in American politics and
you're seeing it happen here with
President Trump's comments this is how
the right is reading it they don't feel
like there's an actual open honest
question being asked as to whether
President Trump's comments were racist
they feel like all that's really
happening is for what they want and by
they I mean the left the Democrats the
media what they want is to say they want
you to say yes I think those comments
were bad I don't know if they're racist
but they're bad and then they say okay
well why don't you impeach him and vote
for Nancy Pelosi for president and vote
for Kamala Harris for president why
can't you admit that Republicans are all
racists there's a second step that we
know is coming on the other end of a
question that is not honest in other
words and you can see this reflected in
the polling data so there are two polls
that are out today showing what
Republicans and and folks more generally
think of the of Trump's comments now I
will point out here as well that the
media have jumped into this game where
they are openly calling Trump's tweets
racist so they're characterizing the
tweets and calling it a factual
verification of the tweets okay I'm just
pointing out that the media are damned
liars when it comes to this sort of
stuff because when it comes to Ilhan
omar saying openly anti-semitic stuff
they won't say Ilhan Omar's anti-semitic
tweets don't say Ilhan Omar's
controversial tweets it will head Omar's
anti-israel tweets tweets that some have
called anti-semitic when it comes to
Trump they will say racist tweets even
though as best I can see the tweets are
not actually racist they're xenophobic
I think the tweets are see and I do
think that there is a difference between
racism and xenophobia both are bad
they're not if they're equivalently bad
or exactly the same way not all
rectangles are squares in other words so
you something can be xenophobic and
racist it can be xenophobic and not
racist it can be bad and not xenophobic
or racist these distinctions do matter
in American politics and gradations
matter in American palates
as well there are lots of various shades
of bad in other words and it's somewhat
troubling that people are so focused in
on president trumping the root of all
evil for what are admittedly and
obviously very bad stupid ridiculous
tweets but they are utterly unbothered
by Ayane Presley going out there and
saying that black people are not black
unless she agrees with them or in gay
people are not gay unless she agrees
with them it's pretty amazing ok so
here's what the polls show coming out of
this latest brouhaha there's a poll that
was printed by USA Today and Ipsos a
clear majority of Americans say
president Trump's tweets targeting for
minority congresswoman were on American
but most Republicans say they agree with
his comments an illustration of the
nation's sharp partisan divide on issues
of patriotism and race more than
two-thirds of those aware of the
controversy some 68 percent called
Trump's tweets offensive among
Republicans alone however 57 percent
said they agreed with tweets that told
the congresswoman to go back to their
original countries and a third strongly
agreed with them so what are Republicans
hearing when they hear that poll I don't
think that what they're actually hearing
is were the tweets good I know the
people are gonna this is not me reading
chicken entrails again my my actual
assessment of this knowing conservatives
better than anyone in the media my
actual assessment is that conservatives
and Republicans when they are asked this
question our hearing are you willing to
condemn a president Trump as an American
and racist so that we can press forward
Nancy Pelosi in the squad in other words
people are reading the consequence of
the poll question not merely the poll
question which happens on the left as
well you see this pretty often on the
left as well people will ask people do
you condemn socialism and folks on the
Left who may not even know what
socialism is will read the second order
question there as will I condemn the
squad for example and they'll say no
socialism is fine with me
so again that poll shows that 57% said
they agreed with the tweets now that's a
pretty low number that really is
remember Trump has over 90 percent
approval rating among Republicans only
57% of Republicans said they agreed with
his tweet so you know I'm gonna I'm
gonna put it out there that most
Republicans are actually not
particularly happy with President
Trump's tweets but they're not going to
tell the media that 59% of people across
the country called the two
on American and again I do think that it
is in unamerican thing to tell people to
go back to their home country based on
political disagreement I actually think
that it's a none American thing to say
to somebody you know go go back to your
home country if they're born in America
I think it's a very bad thing to say I
don't think it's a racist thing to say
necessarily it depends on the context
but I think it's a none American bad
xenophobic thing could certainly be
racially tinged I'm open to that
argument in any case the the polls show
that 3/4 of women called the tweets
offensive this is why for all the people
saying this is an act of genius by
President Trump to make the squad the
face of the Democratic Party
he's alienating precisely suburban
voters he's gonna need for that 2020
elections he can't keep his damn mouth
shut a 3/4 of the women polled called
his sweet offensive independence by more
than two to one said they were
unamerican by Republicans said that they
mostly agreed about overall it's a the
25 percent of Americans is sorry 25
percent of Republicans said that the
tweets were quote unquote
on American which is a very high number
again inside his own party how many
Democrats were willing to say that Ilhan
Omar was an anti-semite
I wonder partisanship is a hell of a
drug nearly three-quarters of Democrats
agreed that this is a racist statement
now 65 percent said that it was a racist
statement overall Republicans were
actually inclined to agree that the
comment was racist
45 to 34 Republicans were much more
skeptical of charges of racism generally
70 percent agreed that people who call
others racist usually do so in bad faith
and that is the key question that's the
key question that Republicans are really
answering they're not answering what
they think of president Trump's tweet
they're answering what they think of you
the people who are pulling them the
people in the media who are covering
them the people on the Left who are
insisting that they call out every
instance of presidential stupidity and
quasi racism except when it comes from
the left at which point were supposed to
celebrate it Democrats 31% agreed that
people who call others racist usually do
so in bad faith
35% disagreed even Democrats apparently
understand that the charge of racism
goes out too often when it came to
patriotism 72% of Democrats 93% of
Republicans said they were proud to be
American in
latest poll so you sort of have to
decode these polls a little bit to
determine what exactly people think
about them I'm gonna get to more of that
in just one second first my schedule
doesn't leave me all that much time to
exercise but if I don't exercise I don't
feel good I don't feel like myself and
that's where open fit comes in I try to
workout every day but sometimes the day
just gets too stacked so I go home at
night I open up my computer and open fit
is there open fit is a brand-new super
simple streaming service that allows you
to work out from the comfort of your
living room in as little as 10 minutes a
day everyone's bodies are different open
fit gets that which is why it is
personalized your needs open fit classes
are led by some of the most effective
and engaging trainers in the world just
press play and work out on your schedule
view on your computer web enabled TV
tablet smartphone and Roku open fit it's
changed the way I work out I work out
with my wife using open fit with my code
Ben you can join me on a fitness journey
personalized just for you again use my
code Ben and start using open fit for
your journey to a healthier life right
this very instant right now during the
open fit 30-day challenge my listeners
get a special extended 30-day free trial
membership to open that you're gonna
love it you can lose as much as fifteen
pounds in 30 days when you text Ben to
30 30 30 you'll get full access to open
fit that means all the workouts or all
the nutritional information totally free
again checks has just text Ben to 30 30
30 and then text them to receive up to 5
marketing text sent via automated
technology to your number consent not
required to purchase message and data
rates may apply membership automatically
we're news you can cancel at any time go
check them out at open fit comm and text
Ben to 30 30 30 you check them out
okay so there's also something else
going on when Republicans are polled
about whether the president's tweets
were quote-unquote racist they're being
pulled on a number of different topics
and that this is how Republicans break
this down I think if we have to break
down how Republicans are thinking about
this so there are several questions they
think they are being asked because the
question is sort of implicit in the next
step of coverage from the media okay so
question number one that they believe
they are being asked they're really four
questions they believe they are being
asked okay there are four questions that
Republicans believe and this is why
you're seeing a gap in the perception of
the president's comments okay
so here are the the four questions
question number one do we trust the
media
his definition of racism right that is
the first question that Republicans
perceive they are being asked do we
trust the media's definition of racism
so if Washington Post calls me up and
says do you think this is racist I
immediately in my in my reptile brain I
immediately go to who's asking me the
question is it an honest broker or is it
somebody who hates President Trump and
is gonna use this as a club against
everybody because the same people who
call president Trump's tweets racist
also justify the activities of Ilhan
Omar and Ayanna Presley and all the
other Democrats who are saying radical
insane things so why would I tell you
what I think is racist when you guys are
not honest about racism you won't even
define your terms right so that is
question number one and so you're less
you are less likely to go along with the
Washington Post's question itself or the
USA TODAY's question itself question
number two do we trust that this isn't
just a partisan hack job meaning not
only do we think that you applied the
label racist too broadly and that you've
been labeling everything Trump does
racist for his entire presidency and
everything that Romney did racist and
everything Paul Ryan did racist and
everything George W Bush did racist and
now you're asking me do I think this is
racist you cried wolf too many times go
go screw yourself and Republicans are
thinking on question number one do we
agree that you are a worthy source of
the definition of racism then there's
question number two
are you partisan hacks and this breaks
down into a couple of different areas
one do you in the media and to you and
the Democratic Party do you Nancy Pelosi
apply a double standard on bigotry in
other words are you fine with
anti-semitism so long as Ilhan Omar is
spouting it but suddenly you're all up
in arms when you think Steve King is
saying something very bad in other words
is this a partisan hack attack so
question number one was is your
definition of racism too broad and if I
acquiesce to your definition of racism
in this particular case and my
acquiescing to your broader definition
of racism in other words if I say yeah I
think these tweets are bad and maybe
even racist am i acquiescing to your
definition of racism which apparently
includes everything under the sun that's
why that USA Today poll is really
fascinating it shows that Republicans
forty five to thirty four thought that
the president's tweets were actually
racist but they also thought 70% of
Republicans thought that the charge rate
is too broadly applied and 57% said they
were fine with the tweets right so just
the 57% in the 45% seem like they should
not overlap right that's more than a
hundred percent so what's the deal the
deal is that a lot of the same people in
the Republican Party who are
uncomfortable with the president's
tweets are even more uncomfortable with
the media using the tweets to justify
their broader definition of racism
because they understand the game okay so
that was question of morning question
number two is isn't this all just a
bunch of partisan hackery like when
you're when you're asking about the
president's tweets and when let's say
that let's say there was a an attack by
a terrorist group in America and antiva
attack on a nice facility over the
weekend by a person quoting aoc
basically talking about concentration
camps and not a single Democrat has been
asked about it by you the same media not
one Democrat in power has been asked
about it zero zero when it's left to the
rebel and the Daily Caller
to ask Ayana Presley and I and an Ilhan
Omar and Rasheeda Talib and AOC whether
they condemned an actual terrorist
attack on a nice facility and when those
women's stay silent when asked the
question and there are no follow-ups
from the mainstream media
who trust you or Nancy Pelosi to ask
honest questions a pound which we should
be able to reach agreement when we know
that you're immediately going to use it
as a tool so in other words should we
should we go along with your partisan
hackery
masquerading as a unifying message just
so that you can turn around and clock us
tomorrow with something intellectually
dishonest and terrible is that is that
something that we're willing to go along
with that's what Republicans are hearing
as well in other words the dishonesty of
the left on a lot of these issues has
left Republicans unwilling to even
answer the question in an honest and
real fashion because they don't think
the question is is motivated well they
don't think the question is honestly
motivated and I don't blame
conservatives and Republicans for this I
really don't because the fact is that
you do this in your daily life all the
time how you ask a question and who is
asking the question is often just as
important as what the question is if you
are asked by a police officer how fast
were you going that is different than
your wife asking you after you got home
so how fast did you go it's coming from
a different source the purpose of the
question is different it's the exact
same question right but everybody knows
there is a slight difference
and what exactly the question is
designed to elicit and Republicans are
reading beneath the questions what it is
designed to elicit okay then there's the
third question that Republicans believe
they're being asked and that is is
President Trump himself a racist meaning
not are these comments racist not are
these common xenophobic not are these
comments ugly but is President Trump
himself a racist and that's a different
question it really is there are lots of
non racist people who say things that
are at the very best racially tinged on
occasion really there there are people
who do not believe that people of other
races are inferior but they're dumb and
they say dumb things because they're
dumb
maybe we used to acknowledge that this
was a fact in American life in American
politics so what people in the
Republican Party many conservatives are
reading is sure those racists those
tweets maybe they're racist but we don't
think Trump is a racist he's how much
McConnell do this yesterday for example
right he was asked if the tweets are
racist and McConnell said I don't think
that Trump is a racist
in other words who's trying to cut them
off at the pass he was saying okay well
I know what you're doing here you're
gonna say if I say that the tweets are
racist your next question is do you
think Trump is a racist and I'm not
willing to go there so instead I'm just
gonna cut you off I'm gonna say Trump is
not a racist
end of story and there I have a question
as to how many Democrats even are
willing to go out there and say that
they think the president Trump himself
is a vicious brutal racist as opposed to
the man says dumb racially tinged crap
all the time how many think that he's a
he's a overt in his own mind is he and
how he thinks in terms of intent and
motive which is what racism is I don't
think there's a strict liability
standard with regard to racism I think I
actually have to have intent is Trump a
racist that's a question that people are
reading into and then finally there is
the final question which is are we all
racist right that is what Republicans
and conservatives feel like they're
being asked meaning here is how the
logical chain goes if I say that I think
the tweets were racist then your next
question is going to be do you acquiesce
to our entire definition of racism
whereby everything a Republican has ever
said is racist and if you believe in our
definition of racism and you vote
Republican then aren't you a racist the
reason that I'm breaking this down is
because I think that people are
completely misunderstanding how these
poll results are working and just what
people think of race in
because here's the reality how many
Americans on the Republican side of the
aisle really stood up for what will
stand up for openly racist language like
how many Republicans stood up for Steve
King the answer was about zero how many
Republicans actually stood up for the
man who's for the police officer in
South Carolina who shot Walter Scott a
black man in the back and then tried to
plant the gun on him basically how many
how many people stood up for that anyone
but when you take a hot-button issue
like this and then you pull people about
it people answer the question they think
they are being asked in reality and so
we're talking past one another because
yes
Democrats doubt Republican motives
because they think Republicans are all
racists and that means that Republicans
doubt democratic and media motives which
is the same thing and why wouldn't they
doubt those motives why wouldn't they
doubt those motives especially when CNN
is willing to go out of its way to ask
the thoughts of Richard Spencer on
Donald Trump's tweets so CNN actually
had Richard Spencer on you know actual
white supremacist Richard Spencer
they gave him airtime yesterday to talk
about Donald Trump's tweets why when did
why is Richard Spencer being pulled
about this who gives a crap about what
Richard Spencer an actual white
supremacist has to say about any of this
the reason is because CNN is trying to
imply that if you support President
Trump then you are like Richard Spencer
and if you think that the tweets are bad
but you also don't think that the tweets
are end of world bad Trump's an obvious
racist he ought to be expelled from
office bad then you are just like
Richard Spencer that Trump's real
constituency is Richard Spencer as
opposed to you know the 65 million
people who voted for the President of
the United States when CNN does that and
they won't ask a single question to a
Democrat about you know Ayana Presley
saying openly racist crap over the
weekend or I or or ill Hunnam are saying
anti-semitic stuff repeatedly they won't
ask Democrats what they think of an
actual terror attack on a nice facility
with a person who's basically
paraphrasing aoc you think Republicans
are gonna have a trust problem maybe
just a little bit I mean honestly see it
CNN bringing Richard Spencer on is an
amazing thing here's what that sounded
like yesterday white nationalist Richard
Spencer who hailed Trump when he was
first elected is among those who are
turning on Trump many white nationalists
will eat
this red meat that Donald Trump is
throwing out there I am on is again CNN
CNN had him on specifically to suggest
that his real base is white nationalist
that's what they are doing that's what
the N and so when CNN asks Republicans
what they think of race what do you
think Republicans are gonna say to that
and many things can be true at once once
and one the president's comments are bad
and they're really bad those they were
bad morally wrong morally egregious
xenophobic at best racially tinged maybe
verging over into the racist okay all of
those things can be true also it can be
true that we do not trust the media's
definition of racism and the Democrats
definition of racism too we think that
they are damned liars because they don't
apply an even standards of folks instead
they're applying a standard that is
politically convenient for them three
they are attempting to paint president
Trump personally as a racist so that
they can for to clear everyone who
supports some racist all of those things
are true all of them at once in just a
second we're going to see how this plays
out for the Democrats because this
battle is not just restricted to one
side of the aisle first than I am big on
getting in shape and one of the things
that I have been trying to work on is my
eating habits right and I have to
develop better habits because I'm pretty
good with the working out but let's be
real my eating I think I hate salad
salad is made out of salad and so I have
a tough time eating salad because it's
made out of salad because gross but this
is where Noom comes in so Noom is a
service that allows you to change your
habits they allow you to change your
eating habits and your sleeping habits
the whole thing is about habit changing
solutions red habit changing solutions
developed personally for you they help
users learn to develop a new
relationship with food through
personalized courses based on psychology
noone teaches you why you do the things
you do and it arms you with the tools to
break the bad habits and replace them
with better ones and they'll tell you
about when you should eat during the day
what kind of meals you should eat it's
not a diet because diets very rarely
work over the long term it's a healthy
and easy to stick to way of life which
is really what you need we're all
strapped for time new masks you to
commit just ten minutes a day for
yourself you can chat with a goal
specialist and numa community to get and
give help to people going through the
exact same things you don't have to
change it all in one day small steps
make up a big progress if you want to
get in shape if you want to be healthier
this is what you need check them out
right now sign up for your trial today
at noon and om comm slash appear Oh what
do you have to lose visit noon calm /
Shapiro to start your trial today that's
Noom calm / a Pierrot the last weight
loss program that you will ever need new
mom / apparel ok more on all of this in
just one second because Republicans are
now in an uncomfortable position but
here's the reality the Democrats are now
at the at the beck and call of the squad
there are some ramifications on the
other side we haven't even talked about
yet
first this month marks the 50th
anniversary since we put a man on the
moon we are involved in the creation of
an exciting new podcast by esoteric
radio theatre called the Powell 11 what
we saw it actually rocketed all the way
to number three on iTunes Apple podcast
it's still in the top 5 overall it's
awesome episode 3 in the beginning drops
today it is a four episode series host
Bill Whittle he's an author of pilot
space enthusiasts bill knows more about
NASA and and the space program than
anybody I've ever met he takes you on
the journey of what it took to get to
the moon and what happened when we got
there and how things went almost
horribly wrong head on over to Apple
podcasts wherever you listen to podcast
subscribe today to Apollo 11 what we saw
and then go and subscribe over a daily
wire become an annual subscriber because
there's so much good stuff go check us
out at daily wire com $9.99 a month get
to a subscription to daily where 99
bucks a year gets the you the annual and
we're answering all your questions now
we've got customers sort of the whole
deal go check us out 99 bucks a year for
the annual subscription that comes along
with the ability to ask us questions
like tonight we have a daily wire
backstage where we're going to be
discussing everything under the Sun you
can ask us questions but only if you
remember go check us out daily wire.com
we really appreciate it we're the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
you
so trouble so Republicans have been
having trouble responding to Democrats
on the basis of President Trump's
comments because President Trump's
comments again put them in an
uncomfortable dumb position because
President Trump did something both
morally and politically wrong here it
was a mistake
at the same time Republicans are not
willing to trust the left in the media
with their assessment of the situation
in fact all trust is gone in American
political life because everything is
used as a club to wield Republicans are
looking at Democrats they're saying why
would we trust you to assess what is
racist and what is bad and what is
immoral when you're ripping Paul Ryan as
tight like you're saying that that
Donald Trump is unamerican for declaring
that these four women have unamerican
points of view in 2012 the Democrats
literally ran an ad with Paul Ryan
throwing an old woman off a cliff in
2012 just flashback to that so remember
what Paul Ryan did to granny and then
it's an actual reenactment of Paul Ryan
throwing grandma off a cliff is a
democratic super PAC literally killing
an old woman okay and then there was
another ad that they cut in 2012 in
which they accused I mean they literally
have them throwing an old woman off a
cliff you think that that doesn't
threaten people Democrats have been
calling Republicans Nazis for years
everyone everyone's a Nazi everyone's a
white supremacist and then you're asking
us what we think of your assessment of
white supremacism and Nazism we think
your assessment sucks so even if we were
inclined to grant that the president's
tweets are bad and crossed lines and are
morally wrong we're not gonna answer
that way to you guys cuz we think that
you're dishonest hacks you're the same
people who didn't mind it at all
apparently when in 2012 Joe Biden
suggested that Mitt Romney was a vicious
racist who wanted to put black people
back in Chains and a democratic super
PAC cut an ad suggesting that Mitt
Romney gave a man's wife cancer I don't
think Mitt Romney understands what he's
done to people's lives by closing the
plant I don't think he realizes that
that people's lives completely changed
when Mitt Romney and Bane closed the
planet lost my health care and my family
lost their health care and a short time
after that my wife became ill I don't
know Mitt Romney gave people cancer Joe
Biden likened the Tea Party to
terrorists according to sources this
political reporting in 2011 he likened
members of the Tea Party who wanted to
restrict spending to terrorists in
American government and yet now we're
told that Donald Trump is crossing the
line guys if you were worried about line
crossing maybe you should have applied
that evenly all the way across the board
I'm worried about the line crossing the
difference is that when Trump crosses
the line I say he crossed the line I say
that it was garbage when Steve King
crosses the line not only do I say that
he crossed the line I max out to his
primary opponent when Democrats cross
the line you guys backed them all the
way to the hills and then you feature
them on national television and this is
where I think the backlash could set it
in favor of Republicans because if
Americans are given the choice between
the uncomfortable dumb bad tweets of
Donald Trump and the sentiments
expressed by Ilhan Omar and the squad
I'm not sure that they choose the squad
I really am Not sure plus the squad is
now turning on Nancy Pelosi again now
remember the same squad that is supposed
to be the be all and I mean this is what
you wonder why Republicans don't trust
the democratic assessment of what racism
constitutes maybe it's because a OSI and
the squad think Nancy Pelosi is a racist
everybody's a racist according to AOC
and the squad they didn't interview with
CBS with Gayle King and they literally
suggested again
AOC and Rasheeda Talib suggested that
Nancy Pelosi was responsible for attacks
and death threats against them we're
supposed to give credibility to these
people this is your this is your big
move here
here's AOC and and Rasheeda Talib
returning to last week's fight and going
after Nancy Pelosi against that wound
remained too close for approximately
five seconds papered over by president
Trump's dumb tweeting and its reopening
immediately I did not say that she was
disrespectful of women of color I found
some of the comments disrespectful and
that was my personal opinion and I did
feel that singling out
the basis of one vote was creating an
opening the fact of the knowledge is and
I've done racial justice work in our
country for a long time
acknowledge the fact that we are women
of color so when you do singles out be
aware of that and what you're doing
especially because some of us are
getting death threats because some of us
are being singled out in many ways
because of our backgrounds because of
our experiences and so forth so having
these women stand up there and talk
about what they perceive to be racism is
not going to be effective with the
American people because frankly they
think everything is racist except when
they themselves are being racist when I
Anna Presley is going out over the
weekend and suggesting that black folks
are not black if they disagree with her
and when ohan Omar is dropping
anti-semitic slurs every five seconds
and Rasheeda Talib is accusing everybody
a dual loyalty and AOC is suggesting
that everything including cauliflower is
racist maybe they're not the best judges
of this particular situation in other
words who makes the assessment matters
in American politics and everyone has
lost such credibility and intellectual
honesty and nobody trusts anybody to
make the assessment anymore there is no
commonality there is no common standard
that we hold to make these assessments
at all and there's a double standard in
the media when it comes to exactly the
sort of material that they find
objectionable so you'll get a OC
suggesting the Mitchell McConnell is
complicit in advancing racism this is
the same aoc who defended Ilhan Omar's
anti-semitism to the hilt the same AOC
whose squad refuses to come out openly
and just condemn a terrorist attack on a
nice facility
he doesn't even have to go back to their
own country I invite them to because we
will win the 2020 election and we will
take this country back because we
believe in fighting for every American
okay and then a OC
ignores in her own caucus so if if that
were her line and I thought you were an
honest person I might agree with some of
what she says there but I don't think
that she's an honest person because when
it comes to Ilhan Omar an open
anti-semite she defended her to the
health Omar was asked by Gayle King does
she regret any of her anti-semitic
comments she said yesterday no she does
not the other women were sitting right
next to her when she said this the way
that we hear and consume information is
very different than how the next person
might so you don't regret your words
either I do not but I have gotten the I
am grateful for the opportunity to
really learn how my words made people
feel and have taken every single
opportunity I've gotten to to make sure
that people understood that I apologized
for it and apologized for anything she
said she doesn't regret a word she said
she hasn't apologized for a damn thing
she's never apologized for anything it's
unreal it's unreal she's sitting there
right next to a Ossie and Talib and and
Ayanna Presley and they're all sitting
there silent as this open anti-semite is
talking about how she's fine with what
she said before and then all them are
like well if you're silent about
president from sweets well you're a
racist what if I'm not silent about his
tweets and I think that you guys just
full of crap what if I think that the
tweets were bad and wrong and morally
objectionable but I also think that you
guys are damned liars and radicals and
you shouldn't be in charge of the
country what if both of those things are
true at the exact same time it's but if
I say that apparently then you're then
you go right back to the poll question
well don't you think the Trump's
comments were racist and if they were
racist how could you possibly how could
you possibly support them for president
because lots of things can be true at
the same time you can say bad things
racially tinged things things I find
objectionable and terrible I've not
wavered one iota in my assessment of
President Trump as a personality since
I think the President Trump when it
comes to his personal behavior has
always been not only deeply flawed but
in many areas of disaster area that does
not change what the left is doing their
broad definition of racism the reaction
to that the fact that we are supposed to
now choose between the Squad and Trump
if you're gonna force me of that choice
guys that choice is not hard it isn't
because I think Trump says dumb ignorant
foolish things on a regular basis I
think it says offensive things on a
regular basis and then I think his
policies match mine mostly and I think
that the people who oppose him say stuff
that is just as dumb or foolish or
irresponsible except I don't think that
it's just foolish and irresponsible in
their case I think many of those people
are actually ill motivated and vile I
think that their motives are nasty and I
think their militarizing Trump's
stupidity against him in a way that is
that is politically viable but I think
dishonest obviously the the lack of
nuance and complexity in our analysis of
American politics is what is leading to
this breakdown the dichotomy because we
can't just have the question that is
asked that out there in the ether
without looking at the ramifications of
the question how it's asked in how it's
answered that I think is what is going
on right here and you're seeing the
Republicans struggle with all of this
because again two things can be true at
once Trump's comments can suck and also
the squad can suck radically they can
just be awful
because guess what they are okay time
for some things I like and then some
things that I hate so things that I like
today there's been a lot of talk about
patriotism and this made me think of the
Amazon Show Patriot now this show is not
for everyone it is supremely quirky it's
a bit it's a spy drama but it's really a
spy kind of drama comedy it's
extraordinarily dark but it's got some
moments that are really very funny it's
more situational comedy then kind of
punchline laugh-out-loud funny it's it's
just bizarre situations and a person
being put in awkward bizarre situations
so if you don't mind awkward humor then
this is the show for you here's a look
at the preview for Patriot I would like
to
to get in front of this election oh my
son but it's complicated
the Iroquois folk music under an assumed
name because he says it helps him with
his feelings hey brother
all you got to do is bring a bag of
money from A to B that's it it's never
easy like that this projects gonna play
out in Iran and Luxembourg Macmillan
comes in those both places like okay
sorry the series is the series is really
weird and quirky and it's got some real
moments so you can go check it out over
at Amazon it's it's got some funny stuff
in it Amazon's
Amazon's Patriot so go check that out
okay time for some things that I hate so
everything is canceled everything that
is good in American life historically is
now canceled a lot of this is
manufactured okay so all of the supposed
outrage over the Betsy Ross flag was
manufactured Colin Kaepernick is adult
he doesn't know anything about the Betsy
Ross flag or Betsy Ross he declares it
racist because some white supremacist
will seize on any symbol of the American
Founding and tried to reuse it for
themselves and the left acquiesce is in
this and goes along with this and that
raises a question Eric Erickson I saw
raised this question online I think it's
the right question why is it that when a
couple of idiotic disgusting white
supremacists say things like the white
the flag the Betsy Ross flag is racist
and and we love it because it's racist
why does the Left respond not by saying
other so full of crap this is not a
racist symbol why does the Left respond
by going you know what they're right it
is a racist symbol and now we cannot
have any of the nice things the American
flag is racist now the Betsy Ross flag
is racist now why does the left go along
with all that because it really is a
tiny minority of people who don't know
anything about history who immediately
jumped to a conclusion based on what the
troller e of the alt right and white
supremacists on gab or 4chan like that
that is what why does the left go along
with that it's it's racist groups have
always attempted to grab American
symbols and use them for themselves the
American Nazi Party used to have rallies
with giant American flags and pictures
of George Washington in the background
this does not mean that the American
flag represented the Nazis or the George
Washington was a Nazi and even
the left at the time say oh well I guess
that George Washington was not so easy
the American Nazi Party is using him
right there the KKK used to routinely
grab American symbols and then use them
and suggest that America was the KKK
good hearted folks and left didn't say
well you know what they're right all
those symbols and now ban but this is
what we're seeing now we're starting to
see symbols of the United States that
have nothing to do with white supremacy
they are grabbed by white supremacists
and then the left acquiesce is in that
grab and suggest that the solutions this
is to ban the symbol so today's example
a completely manufactured controversy so
Yahoo runs a piece about Chris Pratt the
actor now Chris Pratt is pretty
apolitical
by a political I mean he's not a social
justice warrior and he has not openly
come out as a conservative and said I am
a conservative hey Chris Pratt happens
to be a religious Christian and he's
kept his politics pretty close to his
chest everything I've ever heard him say
has been talked you know that has any
political ramifications has been about
personal responsibility and giving glory
to God that's basically it which is a
pretty innocent message as far as I am
concerned well Chris Pratt made a huge
mistake according to Yahoo News what was
his supposed huge mistake
well according to Yahoo News his
supposed huge mistake is that he wore a
don't tread on me t-shirt
what the gods didn't snake now that
t-shirt was okay that that flag the the
Gadsden flag was actually the first
symbol of the US Navy
according to Yahoo News it was
controversial the writing and snake
combo on its own is depicted on the
Gadsden flag a symbol created by
Christopher Gadsden a Charleston born
brigadier general in the Continental
Army it came to prominence according to
Yahoo News during the Revolutionary War
of the United States by colonists who
wanted independence from Great Britain
although it is one of the symbols and
flags used by the u.s. men's soccer team
Metallica and some libertarian groups
over the years the flag has been adopted
by far-right political groups like the
Tea Party as well as gun-toting
supporters of the Second Amendment and
none of those are actually bad groups
again the Tea Party is not far-right the
Tea Party was mainstream right and
gun-toting supporters of the Second
Amendment that would just be like you
know people who believe in the Second
Amendment
pretty much right there which as it
turns out is an amendment to our
Constitution which is our founding
document which provides the basis for
American government of which Yahoo News
is they beneficiary and then Yahoo News
says it has therefore become a symbol of
more conservative and far-right
individuals and according to the Equal
Employment Opportunity Commission of the
u.s. it also is sometimes interpreted to
convey racially tinged messages in some
context they had to go searching far and
wide for that one and then they tweeted
they quoted six particular tweets from
six people who are not verified on
Twitter and have about 15 followers and
then they headline this that Chris Pratt
is criticized for the quote unquote
white supremacist t-shirt now the
question is not why Yahoo News does this
sort of clickbait
we all understand why they do this sort
of clickbait the reason they do this
sort of clickbait is cuz they want the
clicks obviously it's the same reason
that the news created this faux
controversy about black ariel as though
there were scabs and rules of people who
are deeply broken up and concerned about
the race of a fictional mermaid they
were just out there in force again all
they could come up with is like three
people and half and at least one of
those accounts was pretty much
completely fake so they create a
controversy they did the same thing with
the black stormtrooper in Star Wars oh
my god John boyega is gonna be in Star
Wars how can there be a blacks Lando
Calrissian is in the original like what
are you talking about no one cared
no one is they create these fo
controversies but the question is not
why these clickbait sites create fo
controversies the real question is why
the why the left goes along with them
and then you start seeing this
multiplier effect where people like yeah
why is Chris Pratt wearing against in
flag that is a symbol of white supremacy
or like really is it the left has gone
along with this pretty much at every
turn so there is a symbol it is called
the okay symbol right here this is not
me making a white supremacist symbol
this is the okay symbol in some context
like Steph Curry it is the three-point
symbol it's amazing now watch Media
Matters clip that freeze frame it and
suggesting that I'm making a white power
symbol because this is what they do why
well because if you are looking under
every nook and cranny of American life
for racism and bigotry and white
supremacy anywhere you can find it you
will grab it you will blow it up and
then you will suggest that it is
indicative of America's deep underlying
racism and so if you can't find enough
real racism you just make up fake racism
and then
when you do see an instance of what you
perceive to be real racism it's too late
you've cried wolf 1 million times this
how you get to the poll results on
Trump's tweet this is the Z you guys
problem hey Trump's tweets our problem
and separately your assessment of what
racism is is completely fictionalizing
crap because you've been searching for
it in all the wrong places and then
lying about it when it isn't occurring
and declaring that Chris Pratt is a
freakin white supremacist on the basis
of wearing a Gadsden flag there's
something else that's going on here - I
think Ben's homage to the Federalists I
believe was let me at this point
whoever made it it's a good point the
the point is that for the left the
reason that they are so willing to go
along with the obliterated I'm sorry it
was Dan his name is he's from from
National Review I can't believe his name
is he'll forgive me I can't believe his
name is slipping my mind in any case the
the actual that the point that he is
making is that for the left for so many
people who are on the Left they actually
share the goal of obliterating America
symbols because they believe that
America is steeped in racism and bigotry
and homophobia because they believe that
America is a deeply racist place and the
Constitution is is driven by racism and
white supremacy they share a goal with
these radical morons who are trying to
real able the Gadsden flag racist so
they know the Gadsden flag isn't racist
or at least they suspect it's not but
it's Dan mcLaughlin sorry the the the
national view guys instead what they are
trying to do is they share a common
cause the common cause is let's get
let's get rid of these symbols all
together because America is deeply
racist so we'll find places to place our
interpretation of racism every place we
can find it and to if we share the
common cause of painting America's
history as irredeemably racist then
we'll even go along with your lies we'll
even go along with Betsy Ross's flag is
representative of racism
alright this Nikes routine will even go
along with that because it backs the
overarching narrative that everything in
American history was racist you could
literally pick a random object from the
Revolutionary War era and it becomes
racist you can make a mural of George
Washington that ask serious questions
about American history in San Francisco
and it must be obliterated because all
of American racism is not controversial
it is openly racist all of its racist
you can find a cannon
on the Cambridge Commons next to which
George Washington assumes command of the
Second Continental Army and you can or
the First Continental Army and you can
declare the cannon racist because the
cannon itself is a symbol of a time in
which slaves were held the left goes
along with this because it fits with
their perspective on American history
it's ugly it's stupid its divisive but
it's not particularly shocking and the
media do this with nearly everything now
so to take a more a more prominent
example yesterday the Washington Post
ran a piece called the hard-charging
space program breakthroughs breakups and
breakneck and they tweeted about it and
their suggestion in their tweet and
their suggestion in the tweet is that it
was overwhelmingly white NASA and then
this was this is what we should take
away from the NASA space program not
them the incredible achievements of
humanity not the magic of NASA using
what by comparative term for it
abacuses in order to send a man to the
moon you have more computing power in
your iPhone right now than all of NASA
had when we sent a man to the moon you
know it's it's not that that's not the
story the real story is that they lived
in a society where racism was common
which is not a story because we all know
that that's not the story of NASA that's
like saying the story of Babe Ruth is
the story of racism know the story of
Babe Ruth is a guy who had a lot of home
runs also the story of MLB included
racism no doubt at the time but that's
not Babe Ruth is Babe Ruth's when I talk
about Babe Ruth's hitting 60 home runs
that is not an indicia an indicator of
white supremacy
that's Babe Ruth hit 60 home runs it's a
different story to to read racism into
everything including the moon-landing
okay so what's it what's the idea now we
got to take down the American flag on
the moon because the flag is racist the
moon is racist and NASA was racist
everybody's racist
so Karen Heller has this dumb piece
today talking about this back then in
the 60s rocket scientists were the
badass dudes of innovation just the
title was about the highest Brainiac
accolade that could be conferred as in
he's smart but he's no rocket scientist
as NASA worked relentlessly to fulfill
john f kennedy's goal of landing a man
on the moon by decades and it turns the
nation's engineer many of them were
fresh out of school running the gamut
from mechanical to elect
chol engineers because that's mostly
what was taught in universities and
almost exclusively to white men if the
story of the moon landing was racism I
think that you're missing the story and
you're doing it on purpose I suspect
that you were doing it on purpose to
back a separate narrative that it turns
out has nothing to do with the moon
landing it's all about wiping out the
glories of American history in favor of
a separate narrative I was talking with
a friend of mine on the Left yesterday
and she was saying why can't we believe
that America is the greatest country in
world history and is great and was great
and also recognized that America's
history is shot through with racism and
white supremacy and I said well we can
certainly recognize both of those things
but I have a feeling that a lot on the
Left are not willing to acknowledge the
first or explain why they believe the
first is true if they believe the second
is the overarching theme where you put
the focus is the key if you look at the
moon landing and your first take is not
unbelievable America is such an
incredible country that we put a man on
the moon using old garbage technology
and the ingenuity of the human mind and
we did it because we are free and
because we are creative and we defeated
an evil empire in doing it if your first
instinct is but segregation was still a
thing then wasn't it and NASA was full
of white folks yeah we know that wasn't
the actual story at this particular time
you wanna talk about segregation
perfectly up for you want to talk about
the evils of Jim Crow perfectly up for
you want to talk about America sucking
and every aspect of American life being
tinged by this and not up for it nearly
as much alrighty well we will be back
here a little bit later today with two
additional hours of content or we'll see
you here tomorrow I'm Ben Shapiro this
is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Robert Sterling directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Adam Savitz audio is mixed by
Mike Cora Mena hair and makeup is by
Jesuit alvera production assistant Nick
Sheehan the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire production copyright daily weiter
2019 today on the / on the Matt Walsh
show the left is continuing to eat
itself the latest example is the
president of Planned Parenthood
experiencing an early termination shall
we say she was she was fired from
Planned Parenthood for the crime of
believing that only women can get
pregnant also Ayanna Presley one of the
members of the squad has just made one
of the most bigoted statements we've
heard from an American politician in
several decades and that's not an
exaggeration finally I asked a left-wing
doctor to define the word man for me and
he wasn't able to do it so we'll talk
about that exchange also over on the
Matt wall show today